MARY POPPINS with Emily Blunt carrying
the umbrella for Julie Andrews now this
is a role that earns Willie an Oscar so
it's a daunting task for Emily but this
should make her feel better listen to
what miss Andrews told eg aligns LeAnn
Aguilera I don't think I'm involved in
it but Emily Blunt is going to be
playing Mary Poppins
I'm great yeah yeah yeah I am I think
she's terrific and a perfect pick high
praise coming from the original
practically perfect nanny as for Emily
well she's got the look down from the
cinched waist of her coat to the hat
where she pays homage to Andrews with
what else a Robin or a spoonful of sugar
helps the medicine go down so here's
what we know about the movie so far
lin-manuel miranda is in it he's the
Lamplighter Jack Dick Van Dyke is back
but not as Burt the chimney sweep they
wanted me to play the son of the old
Baker and this time there's no four
hours in the makeup chair other new
characters include Angela Lansbury as
the balloon lady and a nod to the
original bird lady and Mary's cousin
played by Meryl Streep the movie won't
hit theaters until Christmas of next
year it has Mary Poppins coming back to
the banks kids after they're all grown
up and we hear she's a little edgier
than the last time we saw her I am kind
but extremely firm it's making all the
rest of the stories that Walt Disney had
stored in his vaults and now they've
made it completely new Mary Poppins
story we're still hoping Julie makes an
appearance in the movie but in the
meantime she's got a new project of her
own
Julie's green room aimed at preschoolers
there's nothing to worry about
she executive produces the Netflix show
along with her daughter Emma Walton
Hamilton and she's got some special
guest stars along the way
Sydney Carol Burnett yes in the last
show is a great friend of mine that was
an ask that wasn't too difficult why you
can catch the whole season of Julie's
greenroom is just starting a stream
today
you